Luc logis premier mois de la lessive
dans l'hémisphère sud
le
jour de l'an non janvier
à plus de 18000 km de Paris ils sont
chaque année les premiers à connaître
les joies d'un nouvel
à Auckland les Néo-Zélandais ont savouré
comme il se doit le passage à 2023 et
les feux d'artifice envoyé depuis les
328 mètres de haut de la skyto
une heure plus tard c'était au tour de
Sidney de reprendre son titre de
capitalement dit à du réveillon
la question était de savoir est-ce que
vous allez boire et conduire question
qu'on vous posez ce matin en 32 16
est-ce que ceux qui nous écoutent et qui
nous regardent plus raisonnable quand
même 74 % vous dites non c'est pour ça
c'est quand même 25 % et ça quand même
pas mal c'est un quart qui va faire les
permis à moins tout ça peut-être faire
des permis en moi s'il y aura quand même
pas mal de contrôle sur les routes c'est
clair pas d'alcool sur les champs
ailleurs les gendarmes seront vigilants
regardez ce tweet de ceux de
Charente-Maritime qui nous souhaite une
bonne année mais qui nous met en garde
aussi si tu n'es pas à jeun je te garde
sous la main autrement dit attention au
dernier shot qui serait celui de trop
autant de cette batteuse chante les
habitants de sa vie quels sont les
horaires au fond de cette boîte
chanteuse ta vie dans tes bras
voilà tu t'abonnes
vous passerez entre amis
2023 nous tend les bras ah oui on fait
le décompte tous ensemble est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord
2023 dans
10 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1
si nous sédions à l'esprit de division
qui nous presse de toutes parts nous
n'aurions à peu près aucune chance de
nous en sortir dans un monde si rude
dans des temps si durs
alors je ne souhaite avant toute chose
de vivre 2023 autant que possible en
pays unique et solidaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des crises mes chers compatriotes
ensemble nous en avons tant surmonté
je ne sais capable de relever celles qui
sont devant nous et d'être cette
génération qui a la responsabilité de
refonder la France et l'Europe pour les
transmettre plus fortes plus belles
plus juste à nos enfants
ensemble
nous allons réussir
feu d'artifice merci ofenbach et merci à
David proto pour ce show c'est fait nous
sommes dans 2023 sincèrement je vous
souhaite une très belle année la France
bascule en 2023 à Paris feu d'artifice
sur le thème de la fête et de l'amour
un million de personnes sur les
Champs-Élysées bien décidé à tourner la
page du covid et de ses restrictions
bonjour bonjour à tous et bonne année
2023 bonne année Karine bonne année
Jean-Baptiste bonne année à vous
j'espère que vous avez passé un très bon
réveillon beaucoup de bonheur une très
bonne santé bonne année Mathilde
[Rires]
et c'est fort de cette confiance que je
vous présente tous mes vœux pour cette
année nouvelle
vive la république
vive la France
un discours adressé non pas depuis son
bureau officiel mais devant la
bibliothèque de son bureau d'angle son
lieu de travail travail un mot prononcer
17 fois par le Président de la
République travaille un choix très
critiqué par le position on a
l'impression à écouter Emmanuel Macron
que les Français sont un peuple de
feignant ici à Limoges
joie
pour certains c'est le premier Nouvel An
discothèque
2023 pour moi c'est que des bonnes
choses et j'espère que
franchement Limoges c'est bien vous
allez bien Geneviève
[Rires]
bon on se calme bonne année à tous je
crois que ça va très très mal sur place
cette lettre Ahmed aussi vous me dites
Roselyne obsédé et eux
c'est pas vrai
vont être au gré du vent du climat des
changements climatiques et c'est cette
variation climatique
de faire travailler ce vinaigre en fait
le vinaigre était sain il aime être
maltraité
[Rires]
[Musique]
le Seigneur Dieu de lui
le ciel et la terre sont remplis de ta
gloire
aux hommes
qu'elle veut faites-vous pour ceux qui
vous regardent ce soir même chose des
conversations parlez-vous mais
écoutez-vous et de l'essence de
l'électricité
et du et voilà santé bonheur
et puis celle qui ont des cheveux on
lâche les cheveux
flamme voilà c'est la fin de cette
édition à nouveau permettez-moi au nom
de toute l'équipe de vous souhaiter une
très belle année pour commencer l'année
en beauté Frédéric Lopez vous invite à
vous ressourcer à la campagne